alors lequel je vais mettre aujourd'hui
j'hésite un peu
en revanche ce qui doit devenir un
réflexe c'est la manière dont on pose et
dont on retire le masque d'abord on
commence par se laver les mains avec du
gel hydro alcoolique ou du sein j'ai
déjà fait une capsule de des confinés
sur le sujet puis on repère le haut du
masque c'est facile certains d'entre eux
sont en plus équipés d'une barrette
métallique c'est encore plus simple on
pose le masque sur le visage
puis on passe les élastiques
on vérifie que le nez et la bouche sont
bien recouvert jusqu'au menton on serre
la barrette et voilà je suis prêt pour
sortir
attention tant que le basque est posé
sur le visage
on évite d'y toucher quand on rentre à
la maison maintenant on commence par se
laver les mains puis on retire le masque
en manipulant uniquement les élastiques
ou le lien en fonction du modèle s'il
s'agit d'un masque jetable comme celui
ci vous le mettez dans un sac poubelle
qu'il est préférable de mettre dans un
second sac poubelle pour éviter les
risques de déchirure au moment de la
collecte et bien sûr ouvre laver les
mains s'il s'agit d'un masque lavables
comme celui ci surtout vous ne le
mélange est pas avec le reste du large
vous le mettez le jour de la lessive
vous mettez le ou les masques dans la
machine et vous effectuez un rinçage
rapide avec quelques gouttes d'eau de
javel
puis vous glissez les masques au milieu
des draps de bain et serviette et des
gants pour assurer le côté mécanique du
lavage et vous faites tourner à une
température comprise entre 60 et 90
degrés quand c'est terminé vous retirez
les masques et vous les mettez au
sèche-linge
ou vous laisser chez oc cheveux vous
pouvez à nouveau porter les masques
alors je sais ça fait beaucoup de choses
à retenir
et pas de panique ça va finir par
rentrer et puis si j'allais vous avez un
trou de mémoire un pas dans le masque et
bien vous pouvez revoir cette capsule de
des conflits nés ou consulter le site de
l'afnor l'association française de
normalisation
bon alors lequel je me mets à celui ci a
pas l'air mais qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
allez à demain et n'oubliez pas nous
sommes toujours confiné ça n'a pas duré
mais en restant lien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleus vous pouvez également voir
ou revoir toutes celles des jours
précédents en cliquant sur le côté
gauche pour être sûr de ne louper aucune
et bien abonnez vous et activer la
petite cloche